because the guy who approached me was
pretty aggressive
it sounded like a bad idea
if someone comes to you and finds out
you're a screenwriter and you know the
industry
and says you know what i do this other
job in my life but i have this
screenplay that i wrote
i know it's amazing how do i get it to
the right person to get this made
i know this thing is amazing there's no
doubt about it so just
do you know any names that i can just
get this screenplay to
so i can have it made is is the question
do i haven't known any names because the
answer would be no
uh well okay there you go so that that
takes off that box
this exact thing this happened to me at
my sister's wedding
oh okay that's weird because i was
thinking about it last night what if
someone came to you
my sister's wedding last year it was
near the end of the reception
and i had given a speech i was the man
of honor
and it was a i think a decent speech so
a lot of people
like oh do you are you a comedian or you
i just oh i write screenplays so i
write a little bit and um like oh okay
and i think maybe
other people had mentioned that so later
this guy who i had never met before in
my life
comes up to me and he says i have a
great screenplay i think
it's really it's perfect for for you
know he
this audience and here so you know what
can we
do with it how funny i was literally
thinking like what what would happen if
that someone did that to you
yeah and you're sort of taken aback
because
um it's funny because it's never
happened to me
here in la where you think people would
be talking about that more
and so i'm not even in that kind of mode
and
near the very end of the reception it's
been you know a big
full long day and
everyone's tired but still loose from
all their drinks and everything and
this guy who i never met he's not part
of
my extended family or anyone i i could
not figure out
how he was there at the wedding because
he approached me alone
and he says i have this i have the
screenplay he didn't have it but
um he says i have a screenplay and it's
i think it's fantastic and i think it's
great and i what what can i do with it i
said well you should talk to
anyone you know in the
the film industry that you know well
that might be able
to do a favor for you but
i think the thing to
remember in those types of situations
if you're the one approaching someone is
that it is
a favor so you should ask
people that would be willing to stick
their neck out for you because they know
you
this man was a stranger to me and
reading a screenplay is a fair amount of
work
even just from a time perspective so
even asking for that is a favor from
a friend and
i i didn't know that guy and so that
wasn't something i felt comfortable
doing because
if i just accepted screenplays from
every stranger that approached me i
would spend my life reading the
screenplays of
strangers and so
yeah i would i would just say maybe make
sure that you know who you're
approaching if you're going to
say i have a screenplay for you that's
really interesting because it was late
at night and i
i posed this question to david and i
said i wanted to ask you
that imagine someone came up to you
i envisioned it more at a restaurant and
just said like oh hey
i do this for a living i'm an accountant
whatever yeah but i have a screenplay
that i've written and i know it's
fantastic i know it's going to be
awesome what's the next step to get this
thing made and so that was
i asked david his opinion and he gave me
this very long
interesting answer i would never have
thought of that answer
but i think it's a touchy thing because
pete and and
the last thing you ended with with it's
probably not ready to be made yet
yeah and i think um
uh depending on on whether you use that
answer or not or you're able to use
parts of it because
he because the guy who approached me was
pretty aggressive it sounded like a bad
idea
and i was uncomfortable in situations so
i mean that's all the context i think if
someone came up to me
and they were sincere and respectful and
was not doing it on the the day of my
sister's wedding
i i would probably give a different
answer so let me think about what i
would
uh that was kind of a bad version of
someone approaching but if someone does
that and they're they're genuine and
if their question is what is my next
step that i would i'd happily answer
um it's when someone
it's it's it's the fact that i was
approached and
they said what you know can you do
something what can you
do yeah and i think that's that's the
big thing
that that really changes that
conversation someone's asking for advice
and they're can ask respectfully and
they say
i don't do this for a living i am you
said an accountant or something else
but i have a really great screenplay
idea
i would probably ask who else thinks
it's a great idea
and if they don't have
any answer to that other than themselves
i would say then
you're not sure yet and you should give
it to people to read
if if other people are saying it's great
even if they're
at first friends and family then go to
the next step and give it to other
people look
online for you know
message boards and on twitter people are
always trading scripts back and forth
trade it with someone who has no
stock in their personal relationship
with you and is willing to tell you if
it's great or not and you can tell them
hey i don't need any notes i just want
to know if this is
good and they can give you a one-note
reply of yes i think it's good or no i
think it needs some work
and if you continually get people saying
yes i think this is good eventually
it will find the hands of someone who
can get it into the hands of someone
who wants to do something with it
but i'd say for just recognize that
everyone else
working in los angeles and trying to
work in los angeles and elsewhere in
within the industry
also has a screenplay that they think is
good and they have written
at least five times as many as
you now you might have a unique
perspective because you're
not if you are an accountant for a huge
firm and you have some really
interesting stories from that firm you
might have a good screenplay about that
does that necessarily mean the
screenplay you have written is a good
screenplay about that
i'm not sure but you have a perspective
but you just might not have a
screenwriting craft
so you might want to partner up with
someone who does
that you trust and it might take some
time to build those relationships and to
find those people
but screenwriting is not
a hobby that
usually turns into just a success it
might happen but i think it's very rare
so if you have a screenplay that you
think is good
there's a shot that it might go
somewhere but
it might just exist as a really good
screenplay for you
i think it's interesting too what you
said it's not so much
don't approach somebody and say what can
you do for me
do it from the what can i do to get it
out there and not
put the onus on you
yeah i think
asking for advice i'm always happy to
to talk about and i think
whenever someone asks me for advice i
always end up asking a lot of questions
because there is no
one way to do anything
in hollywood so it's always about kind
of well how are you
where are you right now and what is the
best possible avenue to achieve what you
want to achieve so i'll always end up
just asking a lot of questions
before figuring out what i would
recommend
and that i'll end up talking forever
because everyone loves to give
advice it's very flattering to be asked
for advice it's not very flattering to
be asked to do something for someone
and so
figuring out that which one of those
conversations
it's going to be i think is
on my end crucial to figuring out how
much i want to really engage with this
person or maybe shut it down before
the ask is coming down the line i
have a sort of
self policy of
[Music]
uh asking anyone to
read my work in like social settings i
have
friends that we have understandings with
hey when you have something can you send
it to me for notes and
um if you have something i'll give you
notes
but that understanding already exists
before i'm going to send it to them
but if i'm meeting with someone for
coffee to talk about my script
and they haven't offered to read it i
will just not
ask them to read it now maybe there are
places and times that i could have done
that it would have been fine
but more often than not i get asked
can i read your script so i found that i
don't actually need to
ask i can just have a genuine
conversation with someone
and if they're interested they will ask
and if they're not interested
then i would have been wasting my time
and theirs to ask them to read it anyway
if they
if i tell them kind of what my story is
about and they want to read it they're
going to ask for it you don't have to go
around offering your screenplay
if you have a good idea and you say hey
i have an idea for a screenplay
it's kind of about this and i'm
interested in it i probably will ask for
it
if they're interested and they have the
bandwidth
to read it they will probably ask for it
if you ask them to read it
already puts them a little bit on their
heels
because now it feels like an assignment
and well i wasn't necessarily interested
in it so i don't know
now i have to gauge like is it worth
in this conversation having this little
attention where i have to now say
no i don't want to read it right now or
i don't know come back to me when you
think it's ready
um you can usually get a sense from
someone of
how they're talking about it and
where they might be both in their career
as a screenwriter or in
their their project itself kind of where
they are in the process
and if it's something that you want to
do and if it is
at a point where i'm interested in
reading it i would i would ask for it
and i think that
in most of my experiences people have
treated me the same
i rarely have to offer my work
explicitly for someone to ask for it and
if someone doesn't ask for it it
probably wouldn't have been in their
wheelhouse anyway yeah and maybe it's
also too like an
industry protocol like the unspoken sort
of thing where
maybe when people are new to la or just
to
the world screenwriting in general it's
just pitching whoever
but i've seen people in industry events
just be
just brutally aggressive and it's a turn
off i've watched them with other people
with
producers and different things and well
how do i get in contact with you oh
look i'm on the internet you can just
look me up you know and they're just
like hounding this person and i'm
thinking
i don't think this is working for them
but i could be wrong but
i think there's a there's just a way to
do it and i think
it takes time to know that that's really
not the avenue
yeah i think there's some people who
have figured that out they're
they're charming they're able to get in
there and get people to read
their work i am not one of those
people and so i just
once i stopped trying to figure out how
to
get people to read my work and just be a
little bit more
open and conversational about my work i
ended up getting a lot more read
requests from that
because i think people felt like i'm not
trying to sell them on anything
i'm just talking and
of the people that have read my work
since then those
relationships and conversations have all
been better because it's all people who
have reached out to
for to me to read my work so they're not
it wasn't something that was forced upon
them so it's naturally i'm gonna have a
better
success rate if that's what you want to
call it of people that are resonating
with what i'm
doing yeah and i think if people feel
safe with boundaries and they
they see that you're not going to just
totally hound them about something
i think they're more apt to be open to
yeah and i will say i've been that other
person that
is not getting red and i feel like i
have to get something in someone's hands
and i mean it's
it it comes uh it feels desperate
because it is
a little bit desperate i've been in
those desperate situations where i feel
like i have not had any screenwriting
traction
for months and
i totally sympathize with everyone
that's in that situation and
you ever everyone will i i've done it i
will probably do it again
everyone's been there it's not it's
something that we can
i think work on but
i think it's human to be desperate for
validation but also for getting things
going for your career
right but if someone's in the restroom
and you're like waiting outside trying
to pitch them i think maybe that's
i mean i'm not saying you're doing that
but i've heard of other people where
that's happened
yeah i probably wouldn't wait outside a
restroom i would not in any situation
i would not advise that or they're at a
dinner with family and
and i've seen that as well and someone
approaches them and
you know forgive me i just need a moment
of your time and i think that's
that's that's a real touchy thing to to
do that you know
yeah and i think one of the things to do
to avoid situations like that is to
try and attend as many industry
events as possible because people are
going to be a lot more open
in those situations because someone that
is there is there to
engage with that part of their life
someone who is at dinner with family
is not in a professional setting and
they're not there to talk about
your work they're there to be with their
family so if you want to be in the
situations where you can approach people
and talk about what you're working on
and meet people then you need to be
attending those events and not chasing
people down in other areas of their
lives
right because it could actually be a
fantastic script and now you've lost
that opportunity
right because the approach was wrong so
yeah right and i think
also putting the relationship over your
specific project is also something
that's really
important because you might have
a great script and you make a really
bad first impression and they're not
going to work want to work with you on
that great script
but if you make a good first impression
and your script isn't that great but
they
really like you and they say
this one might not be for me but keep in
touch it was really fun talking with you
then there might be something down the
line
when you do have a great script or you
have a great script and it's just not
something that they're interested in
right now but you make that bad first
impression and you burn that bridge
so a relationship is something that can
pay dividends over time and
also is just more honest and treats
people as ends and not means
so always prioritize that
over i need you to read this right now i
need
i got to get this made it's so good
you